que les risques de réchauffement de la planète
sont plus importants que le risque d'un incident nucléaire,
qui est certainement possible et est un problème très sérieux.
Cependant, je pense qu'il y a une solution sans perdants,
où les deux camps peuvent gagner ce débat,
si on fait face à la situation
ou ce sont des restrictions de carbone sur la planète
ou c’est mourir.
Et au Sénat des États-Unis,
on a besoin du support des deux partis --
seulement un ou deux votes sont nécessaires --
pour faire avancer le réchauffement climatique à travers le Sénat,
et cette audience peut aider.
Si nous faisons avancer ça, Mark résoudra ces problèmes. Merci Chris.
CA: Merci Rod Beckstrom. Contre.
David Fanton: Je suis David Fanton. Je voudrais juste deux-trois choses.
La première : soyez conscients de la propagande.
La propagande de l'industrie
a été très, très forte.
Et nous n'avons pas eu
l'autre côté de l'argument largement diffusé
pour que les gens puissent arriver à leurs propres conclusions.
Soyez conscients de la propagande.
Deuxièmement, pensez à ceci.
Si nous construisons des centrales nucléaires,
tous ces déchets
vont consister en centaines, sinon des milliers,
de camions et de trains,
se déplaçant à travers le pays chaque jour.
Dites-moi qu'ils ne vont pas avoir d'accidents.
Dites-moi que ces accidents ne vont pas
mettre dans l'environnement
des matières toxiques pour des centaines de milliers d'années.
Et ensuite dites-moi que chacun de ces camions et trains
ne sont pas des cibles potentielles pour les terroristes.
CA: Merci.
Pour.
N'importe qui d'autre? Allez-y.
Alex: Salut, je suis Alex. Je voulais juste dire,
je suis depuis le début un grand fan des énergies renouvelables.
J'ai des panneaux solaires sur mon toit.
J'ai de la géothermie
et un moulin à eau.
Et je suis très pour ce genre de choses.
Cependant, il y a un problème d'arithmétique ici.
La possibilité du soleil
de briller, du vent de souffler, de la pluie de tomber,
Ne sont tout simplement pas assez tout accumulé.
Si nous voulons garder les lumières allumées,
on a en fait besoin d'une solution
qui va continuer de fonctionner tout le temps.
J'ai fait campagne contre les armes nucléaires dans les années 80,
et je continue de le faire actuellement.
Mais nous avons une opportunité
de les recycler en quelque chose de plus utile
qui nous permet d'avoir de l'énergie tout le temps.
Finalement, le problème arithmétique ne va pas s'en aller.
Nous n'aurons pas assez d'énergie à partir des renouvelables.
On a besoin d'une solution qui en génère tout le temps.
Si nous voulons garder les lumières allumées,
le nucléaire c'est la solution.
CA: Merci.
Quelqu'un d'autre contre?
Homme: La dernière personne qui était en faveur a annoncé
que nous n'avons pas assez
de sources renouvelables alternatives.
Et ceux qui sont "contre" ici
ont été clairs qu'en fait nous en avons.
Et donc l'illusion
que nous avons besoin de cette ressource
Que nous pouvons le réaliser dans le temps imparti,
qui est significatif, n'est pas impossible.
Je vais aussi ajouter autre chose.
Ray Kurzweil et tous les autres --
nous savons que la courbe augmente de façon exponentielle.
On ne peut pas s’intéresser aux technologies de pointe renouvelables
et dire : "C’est tout ce que nous avons."
Car dans 5 ans, ça vous épatera
ce que nous aurons comme alternatives
à cet horrible et désastreux nucléaire.
CA: Un bon point. Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Donc chacun a le droit seulement à quelques phrases --
30 secondes chacun
pour résumer.
Votre conclusion, Stewart.
SB: J'ai aimé votre graphique du "tout s'équilibre"
que vous avez là.
C'était un jour ensoleillé et une nuit venteuse.
Et récemment en Angleterre
ils ont eu un coup du sort.
Tout le vent dans tout le pays
s'est arrêté pendant une semaine.
Aucune de ces choses ne fonctionnait.
Comme d'habitude, ils ont acheté de l'électricité nucléaire en France.
2 gigawatts arrivent à travers le Tunnel sous la Manche.
Ça arrive tout le temps.
Avant je m'inquiétais du facteur 10 000 ans.
Le fait est, nous utiliserons les déchets nucléaires comme carburant
dans la quatrième génération de réacteurs en train d'arriver.
Spécialement les petits réacteurs qui vont de l'avant.
Nathan Myhrvold dit -- et je pense que c’est le plan d'action --
va faire passer une loi au Congrès
pour que la commission de régulation nucléaire
commence à avancer plus vite sur ces petits réacteurs
dont nous avons beaucoup besoin, ici et dans le monde.
(Applaudissements)
MJ: Donc nous avons analysé la demande
heure par heure et l'approvisionnement
pour le solaire, le vent et avec des données pour la Californie.
Et on peut satisfaire la demande, heure par heure,
pour presque toute l'année.
Maintenant, avec un regard sur les ressources,
nous avons développé la première carte du monde des vents,
uniquement avec les données à 80 mètres.
On sait quelles sont les ressources. Vous pouvez couvrir 15%.
15% de tous les USA
a des vents assez rapides pour avoir des prix compétitifs.
Et il y a beaucoup plus de solaire qu'il n'y a de vent.
Il y a beaucoup de ressources. On peut les rendre fiables.
CA: Ok. Merci, Mark.
(Applaudissements)
Donc si vous étiez à Palm Springs...
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ehonté. Ehonté. Ehonté.
Donc, la communauté TED,
je m'en remets à vous si ce dont le monde a besoin maintenant
c'est de l'énergie nucléaire.
Tout ceux en faveur, levez vos mains.
(Cris)
Tout ceux contre.
Ooooh.
Maintenant ceci c'est – a mon avis…
Levez… les mains en l’air si vous avez changé d'avis pendant le débat,
ceux qui ont voté différemment.
Ceux d'entre vous qui ont changé d'avis
en faveur du "pour"
levez les mains.
Ok. Donc voici ce qu'on peut dire.
Chaque personne a gagné des supporters,
mais à mon avis,
l'avis de la communauté TED à changé
d’environ 75-25
à environ 65-35
en faveur, en faveur.
Vous avez gagné tous les deux. Je vous félicite tous les deux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)